boy yeah you ready Troy y'all ready Troy  west trail my next-door dude right next  door  I woulda guessed you were from Long  Island when's that  for people that talk like you come from  I'm bored as a mother dude I've been  here for like three days on board time  will you do do for fun nothing this is  it this is what I got for you no we got  some things what  don't stay like a wall if you say mommy  did you consider that I mean how could  you have somebody held prisoner in a  basement and and working in a police  station at the same time trick  photography  okay that's not what I'm asking listen  closely what I'm asking is in the  reality of this movie where there's only  one character right okay how could you  what what exactly would I agree with mom  very taut Sybil meets I don't know  dressed to kill cool I really like  Trista kill